p d'abord donc notre débat politique
avec une candidate du rassemblement
national qui tire profit de sa campagne
de terrain sandra cerqueira
partie avant tout le monde en campagne
entre visites de marché et meetings
modeste marine le pen a joué la carte de
la proximité
ma campagne à moi je les fais de manière
sérieuse je suis allé sur le terrain
depuis plus de six mois maintenant bien
placé dans les sondages la candidate et
rennes n'a voulu prendre aucun risque en
jouant la sobriété incarner au maximum
l'alternance sans faire la moindre vague
avec un programme tout aussi radical sur
le fond derrière une image adoucie il y
avait beaucoup moins je dirais de
beauzelle avait déjà posé dans les
campagnes précédentes les choses les
plus dures contre les immigrés contre
l'islam toutes ces choses là elle les
avait déjà posé elle n'avait pas besoin
de les rappeler elle le faisait mais de
façon beaucoup plus douce et calme quand
eric zemmour marine le pen a su résister
à l'effet zemmour et aux attaques de son
camp et a su faire oublier ses positions
pro poutine d'abord opposé aux sanctions
contre la russie est favorable à une
sortie de l'otan elle a réussi à
esquiver les critiques en se concentrant
sur le pouvoir d'achat elle va par
exemple proposer 2 de faire baisser les
taxes sur le pétrole sur le gaz pour que
les français payent moins cher leur
pétrole et le gaz c'est une mesure qui
d'une certaine façon n'aura qu'un temps
au café des réponses très court-termiste
mais qui dans une campagne électorale
peuvent laisser penser à un certain
nombre de personnes qu'elle est de leur
côté du côté des plus faibles de côté
dessus du côté de ceux qui n'ont pas
trop de moyens contrairement à
l'électorat d'emmanuel maquereau ou
d'eric zemmour dans un éventuel second
tour marine le pen est mesurée entre 45
et 47 % des intentions de vote selon les
instituts un niveau record elle pourrait
bénéficier de reports de voix des
électorats heller zemmour voir mélenchon
et d'un front républicain moins efficace
qu'en 2017 et comme tous les soirs cette
semaine dans ce sens public notre
premier débat est donc consacrée à
l'élection
résidentiel au dynamique de campagne et
je vous présente mes invités ce soir
joséphine staron soir bienvenue vous
êtes directrice d'études des relations
internationales du cercle de réflexion
sinopia hauteur de europe la solidarité
contre le naufrage aux éditions sinopia
justement benjamin morel bonsoir soit
via un menu maître de conférences en
droit public à l'université paris 2
panthéon assas j'accueille également
gérer pelletier bonsoir à vous êtes
directeur des études à la fondation jean
jaurès qui vient de publier ce rapport
consacré à marine le pen le dossier le
pen idéologie images électorat
j'accueille les ti siècle pas bon sens
les mains xiao de vous retrouver
bienvenue vous êtes éditorialiste
politique à mes côtés tous les mardis et
tous les jeudis dans cette émission
jerry peine-t-il je m'appuie sur le
rapport que la fondation jean jaurès
vient de publier pour démarrer ce débat
avec vous ce puisqu'on est dans la
foulée du reportage comme un devoir sur
la dynamique marine le pen comment vous
vous analysé cette cette dynamique on
parlait d'une campagne de terrain
finalement une campagne j'allais dire à
bas bruit mais en tout cas pas forcément
sur médiatisé est ce que c'est un
élément à prendre en compte ouais c'est
un élément à prendre en compte il ya un
élément qui est très intéressant c'est
notamment la présence par exemple sur
les réseaux sociaux des différentes
communautés des candidats quand vous
analysez effectivement ce qui s'est
passé par exemple au mois de février au
mois de mars vous voyez qu'il ya une sur
représentation d'un certain nombre de
communautés et notamment par exemple la
communauté eric zemmour est donc
effectivement on a eu le sentiment
d'avoir une sur-représentation abandonné
et d'eric zemmour que c'est lui
effectivement qui a structuré aussi une
partie de 2,2 de la campagne mais marine
le pen est très peu présente et la
communauté effectivement de marine le
pen par exemple est très peu présente
sur les réseaux sociaux et elle l'a dit
elle elle a fait effectivement une
campagne de terrain une campagne à bas
bruit elle a effectivement esquivé
finalement les coups elle a esquivé les
polémiques et c'est très bien sorti
effectivement de la séquence quand même
poutine où elle aurait dû normalement
entre guillemets être victimes au même
maltais victimes du conflit ukrainien
marine le pen arrive et rhuys
effectivement à esquiver ça on sent une
campagne effectivement à hauteur d'homme
je dirais et avec des sujets
effectivement de préoccupation qui font
partie des figures imposées de cette
campagne présidentielle à savoir le
pouvoir d'achat et ce qui est très
intéressant quand vous regardez
l'évolution de marine le pen s'est
notamment son évolution en terme d'image
entre 2017 et aujourd'hui elle suscite
toujours le même niveau d'inquiétude par
rapport à ce qu'on autant en 2017 mais à
peu près au même niveau d'ailleurs que
les autres candidats donc ça c'est très
intéressant par contre elle a une
stature présidentielle
en tout cas que lui confèrent les
français qui est plus importante que ce
qu'il pensait de marine le pen a ses
défauts du budget sur des campagnes quoi
c'est sa troisième campagne
présidentielle doit absolument
accumulation sentiment effectivement que
finalement elle fait maintenant partie
du jeu et il ya un élément sûr lesquels
elle est en tête parmi l'ensemble des
candidats c'est le sentiment que les
gens ont calé finalement proche de leurs
préoccupations qu'elle comprend bien
leurs préoccupations et là sur cet item
là sur cet élément là c'est la candidate
effectivement qui arrive en tête par
rapport à l'ensemble des autres
candidats on reviendra sur ses
différents arguments qui sont très
intéressants qui pose vraiment le cette
première partie du débat je vous propose
le dernier sondage de dernier baromètre
de notre partenaire des soirées
présidentielle sur public sénat et lcp
ipsos avec on a cherché à faire le cumul
des candidats d'extrême droite on a une
marine le pen ça c'est le tout dernier
un sondage du jour à 20 ans et demi eric
zemmour a dit nicolas dupont aignan a
deux ennemis bon ça fait 33 % ça fait
un tiers des français des électeurs
français en tout cas en intentions de
vote joséphine star on est ce que ça
veut dire que
l'extrême droite a gagné la bataille des
idées finalement dans cette dans cette
campagne est peut-être depuis plusieurs
années je sais pas si on peut dire
qu'elle a gagné la bataille des idées en
tout cas elle a une longueur d'avancé
sur les autres candidats sur les autres
courants d'idées qui aux yeux de
certains n'ont pas su prendre en
considération les bonnes préoccupations
des des citoyens on à emmanuel macron
qui même s'il n'a pas fait campagne
jusqu'au dernier moment a quand même
accès les trois ou quatre derniers mois
sur sa politique européenne sur sa
politique internationale et on sait que
ce n'est pas une des préoccupations
majeures des français et à côté on à
marine le pen qui a tout misé sur le
pouvoir d'achat alors qu'on sait que
c'est non seulement la préoccupation
première aujourd'hui des français mais
aussi un véritable enjeu du fait de la
guerre en ukraine notamment qui va
complexifier cette problématique qui va
augmenter les prix de certaines matières
premières elle certains produits de
première nécessité donc c'est j'ai envie
de dire bien joué de la part de marine
le pen à ce niveau là mais c'est aussi
une manière de s'adresser aux réelles
préoccupations des français que les
autres candidats auraient peut-être pu
également prendre davantage en
considération pour monter aussi dans les
intentions de vote benjamin morel là on
a cumulé mais évidemment c'est trop
simple et forcément les électeurs de
l'eczéma ou pas forcément
évidemment donc j'ai anticipé la
critique est justifiée mais bon mais il
n'empêche que malgré tout quand on voit
les sondages leur après jour on peut pas
s'empêcher de faire ce de faire cette
addition les électeurs d'eric zemmour
vont pas forcément se reporter sur
marine le pen en cas de second tour si
elle cessa il comme des électeurs jean
luc mélenchon ne se replierait pas
forcément sur yannick jadot voulu vers
sa cible et ya une porosité des
électorats mais il faut pas non plus
exagérer vous avez notamment des
catégories socio professionnelles dont
on sait qu'ils ce qu'elles sont rétives
au vote le pen et c est l une des forces
dans un premier temps d'eric zemmour
d'aller chercher une partie de ses
électeurs qui n'auraient peut-être pas
voter le pen mais qui était malgré tout
prêts à voter pour lui même si on voit
qu'aujourd'hui et bien le fait justement
qu'il ait eu cette position dans cette
campagne est bien créer une forme de
porosité puisqu'actuellement selon pas
mal dans lequel vous avez eu des
lecteurs zemmour sur dix qui seraient
prêts à se replier au second tour marine
le pen donc il a pu représenter un
élément de passage après pour répondre à
votre question en effet ce n'est pas
aussi simple également parce que
l'électorat le pen est en grande partie
des affiliés politiquement par rapport
au discours d'eric zemmour qui est un
discours d'union des droites
réactivation l'identité de la droite
l'électorat le pen ne se sent pas
forcément de droite aujourd'hui en
réalité vous avez une minorité de
l'électorat qui se sont réellement
impliqués politiquement on considère que
20 % des électeurs se sentent de gauche
35% de droite le reste est relativement
fluide il est sensible à une offre
politique et la force du rassemblement
national ça justement été ces dernières
années son offre politique prenez-le
enquête qu'elle fait faire la france est
soumise par l'institut harris est à peu
près un an la france insoumise demande à
l'institut harris de sonder la plupart
de ces grandes propositions sur les
sujets économiques et sociaux 70 à 80%
des propositions de rfi en la matière
sont approuvées par les français idem
pour un sondage ifop de mai 2020 pour
l'humanité sur les sujets taxation des
dividendes etc on a une opinion qui est
extrêmement à gauche sur ces sujets là
en revanche sur les sujets régaliens
identitaire on a en effet plutôt une
prédominance de droite la vraie perle de
synthèse exactement c'est d'arriver à
parler à la gauche sur les sujets
économiques et sociaux en tout cas avec
des thématiques de gauche qui s'adresse
à l'électorat populaire et a parlé à
droite avec un discours avec un large
spectre sur les sujets identitaires et
sécuritaires et ça ça marche plutôt bien
en france mais également dans beaucoup
de pays étrangers on jette un oeil aux
eaux
aux intentions de vote pour les tous les
autres candidats
sondage ipsos auprès steria pour france
info et le parisien avec un écart entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen qui
toujours autour de 7 points on est à 6
ennemis jean luc mélenchon à ses ennemis
pour cent est vraiment le troisième
homme pour l'instant eric zemmour est à
10 valérie pécresse à 8 yannick jadot à
5 ennemis laetitia cru pas ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous voyez se
dessiner un front anti macro non c'est
pas moi c'est plutôt ses équipes à une
longueur et y voit la menace arriver
parce que effectivement vous avez vous
avez raison elle a réussi le pari de la
dédiabolisation de la normalisation et
donc les équipes des manuels macro ont
remis le curseur sur justement cette
bataille contre l'extrême droite pour
lancer la dernière ligne droite de sa
campagne et dans un déplacement en
charente maritime il a d'ailleurs dit à
plusieurs reprises que le rassemblement
national était banalisé il a mis aussi
la responsabilité en partie sur les
médias et c'est vrai je pense qu'il a
raison je pense que les médias ont
complètement banalisé le discours de
marine le pen et ont oublié
effectivement à chaque fois de
l'identifier comme étant d'extrême
droite ça c'était le bataille la
bataille première de marine le pen et
donc oui du côté des manuels macro on se
dit est ce qu'il y aura ou pas
possiblement un front anti mac ont tous
sauf macron au deuxième tour à l'image
de ce qui se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux je sais bien que c'est une
fenêtre que c'est une niche mais par
exemple le slogan emmanuel macron cet
été avec vous et il est acheté sans lui
voilà donc vous voyez bien qu'il y a une
réponse bien sûr instrumentalisé par
l'extrême droite et donc il y a ce
risque de front anti mac romain pendant
une sorte de front et que pour
république inversée qu'est ce qu'elle
dit marine le pen
à propos de ce front républicain
justement elle dit tout simplement qu'il
n'existe plus ça a été très clair c'est
une interview que j'ai retrouvé en
janvier 2022 donc sur france inter elle
dit d'abord que le plafond de verre est
une construction intellectuelle qu'il
n'y a aucun plafond de berck pour leur
assemblée nationale et que le front
républicain
n'existe plus et alors elle communique
uniquement dans ce sens c'est assez
flagrant ce matin il était à nouveau sur
france inter je vous propose d'écouter
ce qu'elle répond à un auditeur qui lui
demande comment elle fera si elle est
élue comment elle aura une majorité au
moins relative à l'assemblée nationale
écoutez c'est une question d'ailleurs
qui se posait il ya cinq ans je me
souviens un certain nombre de personnes
indiqué que emmanuel macron même s'il
était élu n'aurait jamais de majorité et
j'avais dit je ne le crois pas je pense
que s'il est élu il aura une majorité et
de la même manière si je suis élu
j'aurai une majorité voilà ça c'est la
technique de se mettre sur le même plan
exactement qu emmanuel macron elle
oublie que la rassemblement national ex
front national a quand même eu des
problèmes pour voir alliés ne serait ce
que des représentants et puis c'est
aussi toujours heurtée au cordon
sanitaire et marine le pen vous avez
raison beaucoup plus loin elle elle veut
carrément appeler les patriotes de
gauche dit elle à voter pour elle et
donc elle l'a dit dans un déplacement en
moselle c'était il ya dix jours elle a
dit très clairement notre projet est le
vôtre parce qu'il est populaire et
sociale évidemment elle vise les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon un tiers
à peu près 10 qu'ils peuvent voter pour
elle et donc elle veut faire de cette
jonction des pôles qui jusqu'à là était
plutôt un concept une théorie maintenant
c'est une réalité la jonction des pôles
extrême gauche extrême droite elle veut
en faire le nouveau front anti macron
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
idée d'un plat de fond plafond de verre
qui n'existerait plus julien pelletier
c'est très difficile à dire parce que
une nouvelle fois on se rend pas compte
des dynamiques il y aura en fait entre
les deux tours mais on oublie en fait
que c'est entre les deux tours lors de
la précédente élection présidentielle
qu'on a eu le plus de mouvements se dire
qu'ils avaient déjà des sondages vous
savez sur le second tour que donnerait
un second tour entre emmanuel macron et
marine le pen que donnerait un second
tour entre emmanuel macron et françois
fillon mais les plus grands écarts qu'on
a vu c'est au moment en fait de de
l'entre-deux-tours ce moment des débats
et de ce qui s'est passé dans l'autre
sens qu'en fait c'est très difficile il
faut prendre avec fictivement beaucoup
de précautions parce qu'on connaît pas
en fait l'ambiance de pays sur
l'entre-deux tours peut-être
cristallisation qui sera pas forcément
la même que celle du premier tour à
tulle il ya une bascule une logique
différente sectionné y avoir des
tensions au niveau de débat des niveaux
d'angoise d un état émotif du pays qui
va faire que soit l'un effectivement va
partir très haut emmanuel macron était
beaucoup moins haut que entre les deux
tours quand on notait effectivement les
sondages qu'il avait entre avant le
premier tour et à l'issue du premier
tour donc voilà tous ces choses là
peuvent bouger le fait qui est plus de
plafond de verre je ne sais pas ce qui
est certain
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui les
reports de vote effectivement par
exemple de l'électorat mélenchon vous
avez un lecteur à mélenchon aujourd'hui
qu'ils votent pour rejoindre mais un
choix de premier tour qui serait deux
fois plus important à s'abstenir que ce
qu'il avait fait lors du premier tour en
2017 en gros vous aviez en 2017 les
électeurs de mélenchon qui avaient voté
pour emmanuel macron au second tour à
52% aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus de 20%
laetitia groupe alde a dit vous avez à
peu près la même chose un peu plus de
20% des électeurs du premier tour de luc
mélenchon qui voteraient pour una pour
marine le pen ce qu'un vrai élément moi
j'ai vu ce 31 pensée entre 25 entre 25
et 30% de parts contre vous avez 48 % de
ces électeurs-là qu'ils s'abstiendraient
s'était divisé par deux lors du second
tour 2010 est donc le vrai enjeu je
crois du second tour de cette élection
présidentielle c'est le taux
d'abstention qui va considérablement
augmenté par rapport à ce qu'on ôte est
effectivement au second tour de 2017 et
ça ça peut avoir un impact a commencé
pour marine le pen parce qu'on sait très
bien que c'est elle qui a la première
impacté avec jean luc mélenchon sur
l'abstention parce que c'est d'abord
avant que les catégories populaires mais
joséphine ça on s'est quand même une
campagne où on vit une campagne qui est
très atypique en 10 et 100 en coulisses
avant que l'émission de le démarrer
serait ce que par le contexte
international le fait que le président
sortant soit rentrer en campagne l'ultra
tardivement bon bah on va débattre après
de la qualité de l'accompagnement de
macron depuis quinze jours bref mais est
elle que je vais au bout de ma question
elle est tellement atypique qu'on peut
s'appuyer sur les résultats de
l'élection d'il ya cinq ans pour tirer
des sons ou imaginez ce qui pourrait se
passer on peut toujours s'appuyer sur
l'asile à 10 à 5 ans mais ce qui est
certain c'est que on a une part de
l'électorat qu'on dit aujourd'hui
volatiles qui est bien plus importante
qu'elle ne l'a été sur les autres
élections on a aujourd'hui beaucoup de
personnes et j'en connais moi-même dans
mon entourage qui à quelques jours des
élections disent je ne suis pas encore
certain de mon vote je ne sais pas pour
qui je vais aller voter et ça ça
s'explique aussi parce que effectivement
c'est une campagne atypique comme vous
le disiez on est dans un contexte
international est extrêmement tendue
avec la guerre en ukraine qui est apparu
pour tout le monde comme un véritable
choc qui n'avaient pas été anticipées
prévues et qui rabat vraiment les cartes
de la géopolitique mondiale mais aussi
de la politique intérieure avec
finalement une candidate du
rassemblement national qui a réussi à se
démarquer alors qu'on disait que étant
donné ses propos pro-russe d'il ya
quelques temps elles auraient été
impactés négativement par le conflit et
bien il n'en a pas été de la même
manière que pour eric zemmour qui lui en
a vraiment pâti on le voit d'ailleurs il
a chuté dans les sondages depuis elle
elle a réussi à faire passer ça elle a
réussi à dépasser se confie à rester
dans la course malgré tous les
pronostics
donc effectivement on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas tout à fait analyser cette
présidentielle avec les mêmes grilles de
lecture qu'en 2017 mais pour revenir sur
ce qui a été dit sur le deuxième tour ce
qui va aussi être déterminant c'est les
attitudes des autres candidats dimanche
soir ceux qui ne seront pas au second
tour ils vont être face à trois options
la première c'est dire de ne pas donner
d'intentions de vote consigne de vote du
tout la deuxième ce serait dire moi en
mon âme et conscience voilà mon vote
mais je n'appelle pas à voter et puis la
troisième est bien c'est la plus
classique c'est de dire j'appelle à
voter pour tel ou tel candidat emmanuel
macron marine le pen est là et bien on
verra il ya plafond de verre et cylia
front républicain ou oui et c'est ce qui
va rendre la soirée électorale dimanche
particulièrement passionnante d'ailleurs
ça tombe bien parce qu'on vous propose
une soirée électorale à partir de 19h30
jusqu'à minuit avec brigitte boucher à
la co présentation sur public sénat et
sur lcp on compte évidemment sur vous il
y aura des experts il y aura des
politiques et on va analyser et suivre
en direct les réactions des uns et des
autres alors on va parler maintenant
delà de la campagne des manuels macron
steve jourdain vous pouvez nous
rejoindre pour évoquer bonsoir steve
bienvenue heureux de vous retrouver pour
évoquer les le gauche de la macro ni
emmanuel macron qui peut compter sur de
nouveaux renforts côté socialiste espère
en tout cas pouvoir compter sur eux dans
sia socialiste françois rebsamen
françois rebsamen qui vient de franchir
le rubicon françois rebsamen c'est une
figure historique du parti socialiste
ancien ministre du travail sous françois
hollande actuel maire de dijon ça fait
plusieurs mois un plusieurs longs mois
qu'on attendait ce ralliement officiel
de françois de françois rebsamen c'est
désormais chose faite dimanche nos
confrères du parisien annoncé la
création d'un nouveau parti son nom la
fédération progressiste un nouveau parti
créé pour peser dans une éventuelle
nouvelle majorité des manuels macro à
quelques jours du premier tour c'est
évidemment pas du tout innocent françois
rebsamen appelle évidemment à voter
macron ce dimanche c est ce qu on a une
idée de celles et ceux qui vont
rejoindre ce nouveau parti tous les
déçus du parti socialiste c'est en tout
cas évidemment ce qu'espère françois
rebsamen regardé comme le parti comme ce
nouveau parti se présente de gauche
universaliste pro-européen réformateur
beaucoup de termes extrêmement
génériques en fait c'est une critique en
règle de la ligne du parti socialiste du
parti socialiste un pas du socialisme
parce que françois rebsamen refuse de
rejeter le socialisme en tant que tel il
se définit toujours comme un socialiste
mais il nous dit la chose suivante
devant la gravité de la période la
dangereuse montée de l'extrême droite il
est temps d'offrir aux français une
véritable alternative sociale démocrate
car les prochaines années seront
décisives pour la france fin de citation
parmi les personnalités 1 qui ont
rejoint d'ores et déjà le nouveau parti
on peut citer juillette mais adel ancien
secrétaire d'état ou encore olivier
klein le maire de clichy sous bois est
aussi le maire de dunkerque mais alors
steve ça fait quand même beaucoup de
satellites autour d'eux ma grand prix la
planète macross au total huit parties
visibles huit partis de la majorité à
gauche il ya désormais territoire de
progrès le parti présidé par le ministre
du budget olivier dussopt qui est aussi
en commun en commun c'est le parti qui
met en avant l'écologie et dans lequel
on retrouve notamment la ministre barba
pont pie ministre de la transition
écologique et puis enfin donc le dernier
venu la fédération progressiste de
françois rebsamen huit partis de la
majorité au total bonne chance pour
mettre tout ce beau monde d'accord en
prévision des législatives et la
répartition des circonscriptions merci
steve pour pour tous ces détails
benjamin morel
évidemment on a tous un petit sourire en
coin quand on quand on entend ça huit
partis qui gravitent autour d'eux des
manuels macron ça peut faire une
majorité présidentielle mais une
majorité présidentielle compliqué à à
diriger et où l'homogénéité sera
peut-être un peu complexe à construire
exactement d'autant que ce ne sont que
les prémices vous avez d'autres partis à
gauche qui tente de se rallier à droite
également on parle peut-être d'une
possibilité pour certains à l air de
venir ensuite chez emmanuel macron s'il
était reconduit donc tout ça fait que au
bout du compte et les jettent ils vont
être assez compliqué à négocier d'autant
que ces législatives elles ont trois
caractéristiques a priori premières
caractéristiques elles sont relativement
loin des élections présidentielles et
les effets de vagues que l'on connaît on
sait qu'ils s'amenuisent au fur et à
mesure qu'on éloigne l'élection
présidentielle de l'élection législative
donc c'est un premier facteur
d'incertitude deuxième facteur on n'a
jamais eu vraiment depuis le début du
quinquennat de majorité qui a été
reconduite seul exemple 2007 mais c'est
avec un changement de président donc là
on a des députés qui vont revenir au
suffrage qui vont quand même être assez
fatigué par ces cinq dernières années de
quinquennat et qui dernier facteur ne se
sont pas très bien implanté donc là pour
avoir déjà une majorité qui tiennent sur
toutes ses jambes qui négocient ces
circo et qui est à nouveau une majorité
absolue ça va être compliqué vous bien
comprendre que le président dans
l'inconscient la vème république a très
peu de pouvoir il a du pouvoir parce que
soutient une majorité parlementaire
comment fonctionnent nos institutions
celui qui tient l'elysée tient le palais
bourbon celui qui tient le palais
bourbon tient matignon c'est ce qu'on
appelle le bloc majoritaire si jamais le
lien devient distendus entre l'elysée et
le palais bourbon ça arrivait à quelques
moments de notre histoire de la 5e et
bien vous avez une fragilité qui
s'installe
c'est ce qui est arrivé à françois
hollande mais qui a quand même conservé
une majorité absolue le grand exemple
historique c'est plutôt le gouvernement
rocard je n'avais pas de majorité
absolue et qui gouvernait à coups de 49
alinéa 3 ce qui n'est plus possible
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a modifié la
constitution
donc on pourrait avoir un gouvernement
qui grosso modo soit sous un
gouvernement minoritaire soit sous un
gouvernement qui se base sur des
coalitions à géométrie variable entre
des alliés qui seront sous la menace
d'une scission ou d'un départ d'un nez
d'un départ d'un débit partie ici je
vais être très trivial du maître
emmanuel macron en effet dans les mains
de françois bayrou d'edouard philippe ii
en fait tous les caciques de la majorité
qui tout d'un coup pourrait marchander
leur programme donc là on change
profondément de république si ça doit
arriver d'où la difficulté pour la
république en marche d'abord dès avant
même d'avoir remporter les
présidentielles par les demeures une
peine et c'est loin encore d'être fait
un lien mais encore des vrais facteurs
d'incertitude mais quand bien même ce
soit le cas il n'est pas certain que la
présidence impériale qu'on ait connu
jupitérienne qu'on ait connu pendant
cinq ans puis son corps se reproduire
pendant 53 on est vraiment on a on l'a
vu avec le dernier sondage dans cette
émission on prend on prend toujours les
tendances un les dynamiques on regarde
pas au jour le jour là il ya quand même
clairement un trio qui se détachent des
rues pelletier est ce que est ce que
vous croyez encore à une une inversion
des de l'ordre d'arrivée dans ce trio
est ce que ça vous semble possible si on
analyse les dynamiques je crois que
c'est pas impossible en tout cas si on
analyse les dynamiques aujourd'hui vous
voyez que potentiellement s'il reste une
semaine ou s'il restait une semaine ou
deux semaines de campagne ça serait
absolument pas surprenant de voir marine
le pen finalement arrivé devant emmanuel
macron au premier tour de la
présidentielle je pense que c'est un peu
court maintenant et que effectivement il
manque deux semaines de campagne au
merkel et les cours sont en train de
saab sulmont repenser les cours sont en
train de se croiser au même titre que on
voit bien qu'il ya une dynamique autour
de jean luc mélenchon qui s'est
structuré maintenant depuis à peu près
trois semaines un mois pareil la
question c'est est ce qu'il va lui
manquer une semaine deux semaines pour
arriver effectivement atteints de ce
second tour qui a finalement un seuil
qui est relativement bas pour accéder
aujourd'hui au sommet autour d'eux la
présidentielle bon il peut toujours se
passer des choses il ya toujours un
facteur de surprise il ya un élément
effectivement qui est très difficilement
saisissable aujourd'hui celle au
potentiel de participation aujourd'hui
on part du principe que vous avez à peu
près 70 % effectivement de participation
30 % d'abstention ce qui ferait de notre
premier tour de l'élection présentielle
un record le dernier record c'était
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2002 avec 28% et parmi
l'ensemble des gens qui disent
aujourd'hui aller voter donc c'est 70%
vous avez entre 25 et 30% qu'ils disent
je ne sais pas encore pour qui je vais
aller voter et donc effectivement il ya
encore un facteur d'incertitude qui fait
qu il reste un certain nombre
d'interrogations et ça dit beaucoup
aussi le score que vont faire les deux
premiers effectivement qui vont accéder
au second tour dit beaucoup de la
dynamique ensuite qu'ils vont en avoir
pour réussir à récupérer des soutiens
pour récupérer des ralliements et donc
c'est très important de faire le
meilleur score possible parce que c'est
ça qui va me mettre dans une dynamique
dans un entre-deux tours qui va être
très chaud je pense oui je sais vous le
rappeler tout le temps et si thomas mais
quand même ce ne sont que des
projections ces chiffres de l'abstention
et ça peut tout tout changer honnêtement
si les abstentionnistes décide on ne
sait pas ce que nous réserve l'actualité
vous savez bien aussi que les derniers
faits d'actualité on le voit avec avec
la mort du du jeune homme là qui
instrumentalise et depuis 24 heures par
exem ans bien sûr mais récupérée par
tout le monde on voit que un fait
d'actualité peut faire basculer et
donner envie aux abstentionnistes
d'aller aux urnes s'ils vont aux urnes
là pour qui voteront t-il il me semble
que les extrêmes sont quand même plutôt
les favoris des abstentionnistes oui
donc jérémy oui tout à fait c'est à dire
que ma pensée ou départementales et aux
régionales on a beaucoup dit les
sondeurs sont trompés en fait ils se
sont trompés sur pas sur le niveau des
candidats mais sur le taux d'abstention
pourquoi pas parce que l'abstention elle
n'est pas uniformément répartie vous
avez deux candidats qui sont
principalement sujet l'abstention c'est
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen
d'ailleurs si on voit aujourd'hui une
dynamique pour eux c'est justement parce
que vous avez un taux d'abstention qui
apparaît moins élevés qu'il ya quelques
mois et donc à partir de là ils ont des
renforts dans l'abstention si demain on
a plus d'attention qu'escompté nous à
venir à deux candidats qui
structurellement devrait baisser et là
pour le coup pour l'inversion des
courbes entre jean luc mélenchon à
marine le pen s'est également compliqué
parce que pour jean luc mélenchon l'une
des cas les mêmes mécaniques folie
d'exactement l'une de ses ressources
pour doubler marine le pen c'est d'aller
chercher l'électorat dans l'abstention
or mécaniquement du coup ça peut faire
monter les deux mêmes c'est pas tout à
fait le même électorat abstentionnistes
mais vous voyez que ça change
fondamentalement la donne parce que de
l'autre côté si on prend les léser les
électorats pécresse et zemmour eux sont
faiblement abstentionnistes électorat
pécresse pour faire simple c'est un
électorat csp + plutôt âgées il ira
voter quoi qu'il arrive l'électorat
zemmour est un électorat ultra politisé
donc il ira voter la région c'est pareil
et l'électorat maquereau en grande
partie donc à partir de là si vous
voulez on peut avoir au corps des
facteurs de surprise extrêmement
important c'est lié au taux de
participation et defacto quand on
regarde les anciennes enquêtes d'opinion
on voit pas ce que c'est ce que les
sondeurs aujourd'hui on a plus de
difficultés à évaluer on rappelle
jusqu'aux états unis donald trump avait
gagné parce qu'il avait réussi à faire
venir aux urnes les abstentionnistes et
ça on les instituts de sondages ne
l'avaient pas vu non plus donc on n'en
sait rien peut-être qu'il y aura un
rebond un sursaut de la participation
dimanche oui j'ai une question confort
pour mes invitations vous avez froid un
peu bon alors on va couper la clé voilà
général j'essaie de profiter
mais on va couper la clim parce que je
pense que tout le monde va finir
frigorifié merci beaucoup aux questions
sérieuses cette fois-ci joséphine star
on est ce que vous diriez que le premier
tour de cette élection est plus
dangereux pour emmanuel macron que le
second
je ne sais pas si les plus dangereux en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
qu'emmanuel macron est parti avec un
degré de confiance
sur sa victoire un peu trop élevée au
regard de ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui il
avait fait un pari qui aurait et qui
pourrait effectivement être gagnant
encore aujourd'hui un ce pari c'est
suite dira je parle plus tard possible
je m'exprime le moins possible et puis
étant donné le contexte international de
toute manière j'ai de plus en plus de
chances d'être au second tour puis
d'être il a sans doute perdu quinze
jours quand même par rapport à son
timing initial le déclenchement de la
guerre en ukraine vive l'afrique il ya
un peu pris à son propre piège aussi
avec la l'enjeu détente parole qui le
met en difficulté et qui finalement l'
empêche aussi de dérouler de dérouler
tout son programme mais pas uniquement
il ils essayent aussi maintenant de deux
rallyes on disait que c'était la
stratégie de marine le pen mais c'est
aussi celle de macron d'aller chercher à
droite et à gauche des soutiens on le
voit lors de son meeting de campagne
samedi où il a un discours le fameux en
même temps tu reviens dans cette
campagne et en même temps de 2017 où il
il parle de sa réforme des retraites à
65 ans et en même temps et bien il va
chercher l'électorat de gauche en
essayant de calmer le jeu et et en
rappelant que le profit n'est pas tout
voilà on est temps de parler un peu à
tout le monde dans les deux camps mais
là aussi c'est dangereux parce que
finalement quand on parle aux deux camps
et bien est ce qu'on parle à tout le
monde ou à personne
la séquence du séquençage yves cible son
public hier sur france inter ils
choisissent aux médias pour cibler un
public il m'a parlé quasiment comme
professeur alors les deux intervieweurs
était complètement affolée en leur
disant mais monsieur le président vous
n'aurez plus le temps pour les autres
sujets il y en avait rien à faire parce
qu'il était venu ce matin là pour parler
aux professeurs mais les gens ne sont
pas toujours dupe
s'il faut essayer de le comprendre et on
espère effectivement que les
téléspectateurs électeurs sont de plus
en plus éclairés
peut-être un tout petit peu grâce à nous
et mission en tout cas on essaye on va
parler d'eric zemmour maintenant avec je
vous propose
de découvrir si vous ne l'avez lu un
extrait de cette lettre qui s'adresse
aux électeurs du parti l air les
républicains lettre publiée dans
l'opinion vous et moi nous n'ignorons
pas que valérie pécresse n'incarne pas
nos valeurs centristes dans l'âme et le
nez votre candidat de qu'à la suite de
manoeuvres douteuses pendant la primaire
hier je vous propose de nous battre
ensemble dès maintenant pour une autre
cause qui nous est supérieure la france
et puis terminez votre droite et ma
droite votre france et ma france votre
espérance et mon espérance eric zemmour
qui s'est stabilisé j'ai eu pitié autour
de 10% d'intentions de vote au premier
tour si on essaye de se projeter là
aussi c'est un peu l'objectif de ce
débat quel peut-être sa stratégie
ensuite alors là déjà il tente un
dernier coup a effectivement sur le
dernier moment ce qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est qui peut très bien faire - il
peut très bien effectivement continuer
finalement sa décrue il peut terminer à
5 à 6 fois 7% il est monté très haut
mais vous aviez déjà beaucoup de
sondeurs qui disait attention à l'effet
de chuter il peut finalement terminé à
cinq ou six donc c'est déjà ça fait aux
jeunes qu'il est plutôt est absolument
table autour de 10 mais voilà vous avez
encore voilà cessé entre 25 et 30 % de
gens qui ne savent pas pour qui hier
encore aller voter ça peut bénéficier
marine le pen est donc continuer la
décrue pour réaliser moi il ya
évidemment le moment législatives pour
lui et donc tout l'enjeu est de voir est
ce que il va continuer finalement être
un responsable politique à se mettre
dans le personnage de responsables
politiques dans laquelle finalement il
s'est habillé depuis qu'il est candidat
à la présidentielle il faudra choisir
une circonscription tout est symbole en
permanence avec eric zemmour donc
qu'elle va être cette circonscription
est ce que ça va être plutôt une
circonscription dans le sud est est ce
que ça va être plutôt dans un quartier
populaire pour aller au combat
finalement par rapport à tout ce qui est
sa doctrine et son projet politique et
la question c'est est ce qu'il va
continuer finalement à oeuvrer pour
l'union des droites comme finalement il
le disait bien avant d'être candidat à
la présidentielle et comme il a continué
à le dire donc je pense qu'il ya deux
ans je il ya les législatives
d'une part est-ce que aussi va avoir un
certain nombre de candidats lui
permettant d'avoir un groupe et d'être
du coup à l'assemblée nationale pour
porter le fer contre la future la future
majorité est ce qu'il va continuer à
essayer de se structurer effectivement
l'union des droites partant du principe
je pense ce que de toute façon la vie
politique française aujourd'hui est
constitué de trois blocs vous avez
effectivement un bloc démocrates
républicains effectivement incarné par
emmanuel macron le bloc extrême gauche
incarnée aujourd'hui par jean luc
mélenchon et vous avez un bloc
effectivement d'extrême droite donc je
pense que ces trois blocs là vont
demeurer il en fera sans doute partie
s'il va en faire par softbank et dans le
petit club qui a créé eric zemmour il y
a quand même marion maréchal donc ils
sont quand même ultra concurrents et
pourquoi eric zemmour prendrait le
leadership de ce groupe constitué avec
le nom union des droites plutôt que
mario maréchal c'est compliqué il ya une
bataille peut-être fratricide à
l'intérieur de ce club ce qui est sûr
benjamin morel c'est que même s'ils
baissent un peu on verra bien évidemment
heureusement cette élection n'est pas
n'est pas écrite ça restera quand même
la nouveauté de la campagne et on peut
imaginer qu'ils s'installent pour un
certain temps dans notre paysage
politique héritage qui est important est
tout bêtement un nombre de militants qui
étaient requis ont été recrutés
relativement rapidement et derrière une
somme financière enfin c'est aujourd'hui
l'une des grande manne financière avec
la république en marchant dans le
paysage politique les partis sont
endettés les parties sont malades de
leur financement 1 sauf ces deux
formations est donc là en effet l'argent
étant le nerf de la guerre ça peut
permettre demain de faire des campagnes
de financer des campagnes acceptera donc
c'est extrêmement important prêt je
rejoins ce qui a été dit ce champ il va
quand même être très concurrentiel si
marine le pen impose à emmanuel macron
1,4850 de 1 à 49 51 ou même en 45 55
même si aujourd'hui elle dit vouloir
partir ça va être compliqué de s'en
débarrasser parce qu'en réalité le
logiciel de marine le pen et on évoquait
tout à l'heure aux coûts plus porteurs
eric zemmour parle à l'identité de
droite cette identité de droite elle est
assez marginal dans le pays au fond les
gens qui réellement réagissons pas une
offre politique mais une identité
politique par ailleurs vous regardez
aujourd'hui le vote pécresse le deuxième
choix de 40% des électeurs de valérie
pécresse s'est pas eric zemmour c'est
emmanuel macron l'électorat de
centre-droit est beaucoup plus proche
les manuels macron qu'il ne l'ait d'eric
zemmour donc l'espace politique campé
par eric zemmour est compliqué à couper
donc vous avez cette lutte interne
ensuite qui peut déclencher que marion
maréchal-le pen et de l'autre côté vous
évidemment heller mais oui il sera loin
d'être morte quoi qu'il arrive avec à
laurent wauquiez ou de mort sur cet
espace public faut pas oublier que est
ce que eric zemmour peu
devenir le léman entre est en quelque
sorte qui va attirer une partie de l'air
on pense à la ligne ciotti qui ont
rejoint parfois celle de laurent
wauquiez faudra voir ce qu'il devient ce
qu'il advient de l air le lendemain dès
les élections présidentielles le score
de valérie pécresse va évidemment être
assez déterminant et ensuite la capacité
du parti à se réorienter sur une base ou
sur une autre dite nasion n'est pas
n'est pas écrite bref j'en ai pas
forcément écrit c'est à dire que à l air
vous avez en réalité un conglomérat
d'élus locaux vous avez des intérêts qui
sont des intérêts locaux qui font que ce
parti a quand même plutôt intérêt à
tenir il est assez facile quand vous
êtes un élu local quand vous êtes un
président de région acceptera d'être
dans une opposition relativement molle
au chef de l'état il vaut mieux éviter
de vous ranger sur son panache blanc il
vaut mieux justement être dans cette
position un peu d'entre d'eux ce qui
permet à des structures comme l air
demain de pouvoir tenir et bien reprise
en main d'oeuvre qu'on paie cet espace
politique donc la guerre des droites
le soir des élections présidentielles et
même des élections législatives ne fera
que commencer pour terminer je vous
propose trois prises de paroles signées
nathalie arthaud fabien roussel et
nicolas dupont aignan il ya 12 millions
d'indécis donc je demande aux français
de ne pas se polariser sur les sondages
de voter en fonction de leurs
convictions donc je dis aux français
arrêtez de vous laisser influencer
prenez votre destin en main cette
élection a été manipulée de a à z pour
autant le 10 avril vous avez un bulletin
de vote soit vous l'utilisez way et vous
pouvez tout bouleverser soit vous restez
chez vous à râler et vous râlerez
pendant cinq ans ma candidature est un
appel à la conscience et à la
mobilisation je ne me présente pas pour
dire qu au pouvoir je ferai mieux que
macron je me présente pour dire que les
travailleurs doivent viser le
renversement de la grande bourgeoisie et
de son état il doit viser l'instauration
de leur propre pouvoir pas seulement
pour assurer la retraite à 60 ans ou un
meilleur salaire mais pour changer toute
la société y a pas de citoyens inutile
n'y a pas de vote inutile c'est terrible
ça fait des années qu'on nous demande
d'aller vous et avec nos pieds par
défaut
avec une pince à l'insuline et ça va
moins loin heureusement que j'ai défendu
pendant cette campagne des idées comme
celle que vous venez d'évoquer que je
suis le seul à défendre à gauche on a
parlé de laïcité de liberté d'expression
d'énergie de pouvoir d'achat et bien
voté pour vous votez justement efficace
utile arrêtez de voter par défaut
c'était je pense que vous n'êtes pas
dupes un moment temps de parole puisque
mais dans l'égalité absolue des temps de
parole mais quand même on va on va
terminer ce débat autour de fabien
roussel bien vous vous en tant que
jérémy pelletier s'ils restent à ce
niveau on est autour de 3 3% entre 3 et
4 ça dépend des instituts est ce qu'on
pourra dire qu'il a réussi une bonne
campagne présidentielle bat il s'est
passé beaucoup de choses dans cette
campagne là c'est à dire que d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant quand vous interrogez
les gens sur dans les enquêtes d'opinion
sur les raisons pour laquelle il ya un
plus faible au taux d'intérêt dans cette
campagne là par rapport à ce qu'ils
avaient en 2017 beaucoup vous dise
évidemment le manque de suspense c'est
un élément important mais ils vous
disent beaucoup la répétition de choses
ce sont les mêmes propositions les mêmes
programmes les mêmes personnalités dont
il ya l'effet répétitif qui joue
beaucoup sur le désintérêt fabien
roussel c'est avec eric zemmour
finalement la seule originalité l'une
des seules l'origine de cette campagne
là avec un élément qui est que il a
compris que la vie politique et est
désormais aussi une affaire de style
était finalement
une averse si on signe à faire
d'incarnation il faut être bon il faut
être capable physiquement de s'exprimer
avec un langage franc parler en des
temps effectivement très populaire et en
réutilisant des thèmes effectivement que
la gauche avait un peu délaissé à
commencer par la laïcité à commencer par
la république ce qui est certain c'est
que je pense qu'il a redonné de la
fierté aux militants du parti communiste
il à redonner de la fierté aux gens qui
avaient l'habitude de voter parti
communiste et que est qui qui avaient
beaucoup de mal avec le fait que les
candidats communistes étaient absents au
profit de jean luc mélenchon depuis
effectivement plusieurs reprises en ciel
donc il a réussi sa campagne d'un point
de vue acquisition de notoriété c'est
quelqu'un désormais qu'ils aient connue
qui a réussi à acquérir effectivement
une notoriété importante maintenant tout
l'enjeu pour lui est de voir est ce
qu'il va être victime du vote utile à
gauche pour jean luc mélenchon auquel
cas effectivement vous l'avez dit il est
entre 3 et 4 il peut terminer un ennemi
2 ou est ce que bon il va réussir malgré
tout aller par exemple à 5% ce qui lui
permettra de rembourser les frais de sa
campagne ce qui est très important que
ce qui est évidemment important on y
revient à la question financière un mot
de conclusion rien de votre avion il a
plutôt bien réussi sa compagne ce pour
trois raisons la première raison de
présence et on évoqué tout à l'heure le
logiciel politique qui aujourd'hui est
assez idoine très à gauche et en même
temps sur les questions d'identité de
laïcité on va dire sur une position
assez républicaine classique il a réussi
à l'incarner et ça c'est un trésor de
guerre qu'on pourra difficilement lui
enlever le deuxième élément sans effet
la bataille de l'incarnation il est
aujourd'hui visible audible dans un
champ politique qui apparaît un peu
comme un désert à la plupart des
français c'est un acquis extrêmement
important le troisième élément c'est que
ce qui se joue pour la gauche de la
gauche aujourd'hui pour la gauche tout
court c'est les législatives est votre
position votre visibilité vous permet de
négocier des accords aujourd'hui on bat
le parti communiste est en train de
devenir le centre d'un conglomérat de
partis en vue des législatives qui
pourraient s'imposer devant le parti
socialiste et cetera ça c'est un acquis
politique qui demain peut être
extrêmement précieux je veux dire une
demi-seconde de conclusion la réussite
de fabien roussel ces grands échecs de
jean luc mélenchon qui n'a pas voulu
d'alliance qui n'a pas réussi à faire
l'alliance à gauche et donc se présenter
aujourd'hui comme le vote utile et
efficace alors qu'on n'a jamais dit
gauche pendant toute la campagne qu'on
n'a jamais tenté de rassembler son camp
c'est difficile joséphine savoir moa -
contenu non plus je écoutez c'est vrai
que à la fois on a un trio qui se
détache qu elle-même qui a 5 ans et en
même temps il reste de l' incertitude
donc ces deux ces deux tendances un peu
contradictoires envoyés dans l'opinion
reste dans l'incertitude et j'aimerais
revenir sur ce qu'a dit fabien roussel
il parle du vote utile
je pense qu'il a raison c'est les
citoyens français en ont un peu marre
d'être contraint d'élection en élection
à ce vote utile mais aujourd'hui le vote
utile il a une connotation un peu
différente parce que les deux candidats
favoris
l'utiliser le brandissent on a même
genre lui même dangereux on peut dire
que jean luc mélenchon emmanuel macron
qui dit le vote utile c'est moi pour
faire barrage remparts au front national
c'est la rhétorique classique et on à
marine le pen qui dit le vote utile anti
macron c'est moi et personne d'autre et
jean luc mélenchon qui lui en
s'adressant à la gauche tient le même
discours donc cette question du vote
utile et bien malheureusement elle reste
elle reste central dans cette campagne
merci beaucoup merci à tous les trois
j'appelle le titre de votre livre
josephine staton europe la solidarité
contre le naufrage c'est publié aux
éditions sinopia et puis jérémy pétillât
ce rapport de la fondation jean jaurès
consacré à marine le pen le dossier le
pen idéologie images
électorat